[Musique]
c'est un constat je suis parti tout seul
387 que les mecs qui sont et comment tu
vas rentrer je sais pas si ça s'appelle
comment ta ville déjà à l'air doit se
tape je t'emmène
- pas trois elle est où la terre de ses
ancêtres tu vivais c'est pas grave on va
trouver un avion demain soir mais les ou
d'avoir à manger mais non je t'ai dis
moi je traite à dakar demain soir j'ai
un avion qui nous appelons c'est pas
bien mais oui on les avait fait à manger
ça c'est pas moi les buts à 5 y en a pas
merde
la voiture est tombée en panne la
vieille voiture est tombée en panne
parce que l'été vieille usées
bah oui tu es vraiment naïf c'est là que
tout commence
pourquoi t'es jamais venues aux syriens
c'est pas dit si toi comme ça ça se voit
tout de suite que le chemin de 107
continue à guider tepa merci
c'est la terre de tes ancêtres doit y
aller
à
pourquoi tu as fait ton âge tout seul
chez qui pour un gamin comme toi
parce que du véhicule samedi face à
basket un blanc je suis blanc moi j'y
[Musique]
étais pas blanc tu es juste un bon outil
à lundi